[Music]
martin is with us in albuquerque new
mexico hey martin welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
i um i have a charge off loan uh that
was charged off i believe in
uh august 27th or no i'm sorry i'm sorry
uh it was charged off actually not too
long ago it's a loan for eight thousand
dollars and i have a backstory with it
but i just want to know what are the
steps to
um
tackling this loan considering it's only
been about
six to eight months that i have not paid
what kind of loan
well it's just a personal loan at the
time
before i was interested in
investing and saving
i
got a loan when i had a job to purchase
a
dream car i wanted
okay so you're eight thousand dollars to
who
uh it's a it's an online lender called
lightstream okay
all right i'm with you now
all right
george so
why weren't you able to pay the loan
i got injured back in january 22nd of
last year i was a ups driver i fell out
of the back of a truck and hit my back
my work did not work with me and so i
eventually got a lawyer to fight against
eps
we finally settled after a year i just
got the settlement check about a week
ago and i'm holding on to it for certain
reasons and this is one of them okay how
much is the check
uh we settled for 15 600.
all right and have you worked at all
since
uh no sir i've i've been
injured stuck at home okay so have you
had any income any disability anything
like that
uh no sir what are you gonna do for your
career going forward
um
right now i'm going back to school i'm
going for my uh
my associates for business
um
and hopefully going farther than that as
soon as i'm done with that i have about
five classes left for that
are you living with your parents
yes sir yes sir my i'm living with my
mother she's she's been taking care of
me uh since then god bless her wow
how are you paying for the school
uh she
um
offered to pay for one class for it
right now
i registered for two and luckily my
school gave me a 500
grant
um so the bill
came out to 100
good okay very good
do you have any other debt uh
yes sir yes sir i um just before this
call i spoke to nusenda my banking and i
have two credit cards that are
maxed out
um because i was paying for stuff after
i was injured
um so those are maxed out at 2500.
eat your total
total for both credit cards one's a
thousand dollars and one's 1500. okay
they they i tried working with them my
mom tried working with them uh seeing if
they could lower it if she was willing
to pay it off
um unfortunately the only thing they can
do is lower the interest rate and the
minimum payment
are you current with them
yes sir okay that's why yeah
all right and that's all the debt
yes yes yes okay are you up and around
where you're able to do something to
create an income while you're in school
right now
after a year my back is
starting to
get
better i've noticed some improvements
i still want to go
with the doctors because in my
settlement i was i received a twenty
thousand dollar
uh medical
um
i guess just for medical i'm not
suggesting that you don't finish your
medical care i'm suggesting you go
create an income
are you able to do that
i believe so yes yeah you're up walking
around right
yes sir okay then you can go do
something you're not gonna load trucks
again you're not gonna be in a position
to do that you've got a back injury i
didn't i didn't suggest that i don't
want you to go lifting heavy trays as a
waiter you're not going to be able to do
that right now okay you may someday but
right now you can't but you could go do
something that did not require physical
labor and there's lots of those things
available right now
yes sir and you need to create some
income
it'll be good for your attitude and your
pocketbook
with the settlement check i mean we can
clean up this debt today was there
anything else you wanted to do with it
other than i want you to cash flow the
rest of your school for sure
yes sir i uh i was just
my mother and i had a plan um
she wanted to try to settle the debts
and try to lower them um
considering after we if we were to pay
everything off without trying to lower
it it would only come out to
around five grand maybe a little bit
less than that so
um and i'm not sure how much interest
rate or fees
here's what i would do i'd write a check
today and pay off your credit cards and
get some scissors out and cut them up
okay where you never use them again okay
the second thing i do is i'd call this
company that you've got the 8 000 with
and you haven't paid since august and
ask them what they will take as
settlement in full
okay
and they will probably take five grand
or four grand or something they're
probably going to make you an offer
and if they make you an offer that's
less than eight thousand dollars take it
and write them a check get it in writing
from them
before you send them money that they're
agreeing to accept x number of dollars
as settlement in full that's the
phrase you're looking for settlement in
full
oh okay okay uh is there a difference
between uh pay and delete
pay and delete
yes yes sir uh for it's a chart i i just
looked a bunch of youtube videos and i
saw that pay and delete doesn't mean
anything that's that's not even that
doesn't even exist
yes sir okay they pay and delete means
if you pay the loan off they're going to
delete the loan
duh
okay of course they're gonna do that but
no you need the legal phrase is
settlement in full you are making a
settlement and they're accepting it as
payment in full
yes sir so it's settlement in full and
you need that in an email or something
in writing and you keep a hard copy of
it with a copy of the check that you
wrote of the wire transfer that you did
or whatever it was in a file for the
rest of your life
because this may come up again it may
come up again it may come back and bite
you later and you'll have to have proof
that you settled this and got rid of it
yeah i wouldn't spend too much more time
and energy trying to fight all this
stuff you took out the debt pay it off
and move on with your life man you got a
bright life ahead of you bright future
and that's what we want for you if
you've got no debt hanging over you and
you've still got a little money in your
pocket which would be the case here and
you're in school and you're starting to
create an income now your future is
brightening back up again that's what
i'm trying to put together a total life
picture here for where you're going but
you need to go create some income
starting this week sir